good morning Hank it's Tuesday hi
everyone else I'm Rosie Anna I'm John's
assistant I'm also John Hanke Secret
London sister as of way back when to
Hank when people find out that I'm
John's assistant especially because I
live so far away in London the number
one question they ask is so what is it
that you do today I'm going to endeavor
to answer this question but first I want
to give a little bit of an office tour
because we've seen your office in
Missoula Hank we've also seen John's
office energy mouth lift that's a really
hard phrase to say office in
Indianapolis so without further ado this
is my office this is my view these are
the wild animals I can see from my
office this is the foliage I can see
from my office and these are the trees
so that's for the job itself a large
part of my role is scheduling which is
lucky because I am awesome at it through
the combined window of Craigslist shared
calendars on Gmail and Skype credit I'm
able to coordinate someone to come in
and organize John speaks John shirts by
Hughes very important that they're in
rainbow order god I love rainbows
obviously yet someone to come in and sit
in John's car seat to warm up for about
15 minutes every time before he wants to
take the car out I would say I spend
about half my time here in the London
office and I can meet about three days a
week to Indianapolis hardest part about
this is probably the I don't know say
eight hours or so that I'm over the
Atlantic Ocean without any internet is
particularly difficult for doing my job
especially because John often calls me
quite casually throughout the day to do
things like look up words in the
dictionary for him not necessarily for
his next book just to complete the
crossword he says it's not cheating if
he asks me on the upside my air miles
are awesome and the crew at Virgin
Atlantic really know how to make an
amazing gin and tonic another key part
of my role is security testing I feel
like I'm kind of a pro at this because
I've seen every episode of homeland at
least six times
I also remember everything that Nancy
McNally well that just fell down has
ever said okay well now that's yeah well
don't raise on them so just like the NSA
I do spend a lot of my time hacking into
John's personal accounts online just to
double-check all the security levels and
then I also change all the passwords
every like three hours when John takes
us to dftba con 4 I changed that to
change the passwords every 15 minutes
just to be super safe but otherwise my
sister ship is pretty normal standard
stuff the role like washing and
blow-drying John's used tissues and so
that he can reuse them in the name of
sustainability and also ghostwriting
found metal from John to Steve and Jared
and by fan mail I mean
love letters out of all my roles this is
the hardest for me because I am a
die-hard West Ham United fan I have been
known to slip a few references to
bubbles into these love letters I would
admit that Stephen Jarrod is a very
talented player for Liverpool Football
Club but even me a little bit handsome I
do always feel like I'm betraying my
beloved irons but I suppose they gave us
Carol so there you go some of the recent
projects I've undertaken in my spare
time include building up Henry and
Alice's library for the next 15 to 18
years taking them from the joint pits
burned right up to the Unbearable
Lightness of being another thing I'm
doing is overseeing the construction of
an exact replica of the Globe Theatre
and in John's back garden mainly so his
kids could see Shakespeare as everyone
was supposed to see Shakespeare standing
up other priorities include building up
John's Lauren Conrad gifts collection
with a smidge of Benedict Cumberbatch
and the adolescent wolf program just to
keep everyone happy say okay jokes aside
it's honestly the best job I've ever had
it's really cool getting to work with
you guys it's really been honest
thinking and looking back at me in 2006
I used to read John's blog his very
static blog and 2007 me who was addicted
to positive window because the tools I
use now without even thinking about it
to do my job just weren't really
possible then go pout and shared
calendars on start emails that tell me
that it's time for John to put more air
in his tires which he spells with an eye
which is weird so basically what I'm
saying Hank is that we're living in the
future and I'm loving it thanks for
being awesome everyone and Hank I will
see you on Friday
bye